La sucks too Ally's got good food though
great food I mean you know like that
part of me I don't do that anymore where
I'm like you know no I know I gotta
where's the food right because that's
you know when I used to come to L.A was
where's the hookers and then it was
where's the foot and then it became
where's the food right now you're where
where's the podcast
it's so sad it gets sadder and sadder
hookers food now it's pot where's the
podcast dude yeah I remember when I used
to come here and that's what it reminded
me of coming here tonight it reminded me
of getting a hooker back in the day
because you had to like go to an address
and then you had to call when you got
there and then they would come out
they'd give you the right address how
would you know which one to like where
would you find was it on the back page
or like what was there was the uh La
weekly okay uh you'd get the LA weekly
and in the back they had the hookers
um and you could and they just had like
they would say like Hey I'm
you know they would have a picture of a
girl
and it was never that girl right it
would have this blonde girl you'd be
like oh my God and you'd show up and it
was a Spanish woman in her 50s with zits
and at that point you're just like look
it's three o'clock in the morning uh
let's just do this and you'd go in and
uh and and do what you had to do what
was the price back then back then it was
um it was different prices it was a a
hundred bucks usually or 120 bucks
but La is the worst for sex workers New
York was the best New York was the
ultimate because I don't know
it was a better there was a um I think
because a porn was here I don't know
what they had they [ __ ] you a lot here
it was always a scam New York it was you
know it was actually they had some type
of code where you kind of got what you
wanted right
um but in La it was always a scam it was
always [ __ ] like I showed up one
time at this place it was a hotel shitty
hotel and we showed up and uh she was
like yeah I can't touch you you can't
touch me but we get naked and you can
masturbate
and it's like I already gave you the
money
uh now I'm just sitting there and I'm
just I could have just done this in my
hotel yeah what is that well it's just
sex it's a bad you know it's like bad
stuff you know but you think you're
gonna you know hook up like in New York
you would go and you'd you'd go into a
room and you'd you know what do you
think sex work in Austin's like just a
big woman who smells like brisket she
comes out and she's just dangling burnt
ends like pasties over her tits she's
got like bikey tattoos and ashy elbows
she's she's technically a lesbian but
she's making side cash she's got cancer
freckles on her tits yeah she just comes
out with like that dikey green hair and
she's like I sucked a dick once I'll do
it again I got I owe tax money I'll do
it again if I have to
yeah I mean it's um
sexinelli has never been good no
sexualities but horrible I mean it is
your Knack I guess if you're going to
the orgies there's orgies just like eyes
wide shut [ __ ] where has to be I mean
you can't I'm not excited I've never
seen that I know but I just have to
believe it's because there's got to be a
reason that people live here
yeah but the yeah I don't I don't I've
never seen that the sex here is terrible
I almost got I almost got shot one time
[Music]
[Laughter]
I had a girl come to my hotel room it
wasn't the girl in the thing it was some
some angry she was angry and she was
like uh
she she just you know gave me an
attitude and then she but she came in
very nice and she took the money then
she started to give me all these rules
and I was like what the [ __ ] and then
she left
and uh her guy came up
and was like listen stop you know he had
a gun and he was like you know he's this
little white guy he's like stop messing
with her and I called the place back up
and I placed the complaint and I was
like no
this is [ __ ] you sent the wrong girl
it's not the girl and I complained I'm
like this is crap you know I've ordered
from you before I'm gonna tell everybody
I know and then they they go we're gonna
send her back up and they made her come
back up
and uh she came back up and what was her
attitude like then it was terrible but
so was mine okay so I just masturbated
in front of her and I made her dance
what a beautiful story
I go I go Just Dance and she was just
kind of doing this angry just pissed off
dancing and you're just jerking off
angry as well it was terrible it was
like the worst experience yeah I mean
but I didn't want my I wanted to get my
money's worth yeah you don't want to get
robbed no I almost got robbed yeah yeah
I'm so glad I'm out of that sex stuff
though that sex addiction was the worst
that was bad how do you get out of that
meeting a good woman yeah I mean yeah I
mean I I mean because you went from
drugs I went from drugs sex
food was the first right back when I was
a kid yeah and then it went to drugs
and went back to food when I went to
rehab then it went to sex and sex uh
after I you know got sober sex was I
just got addicted to it it was terrible
it wasn't bad were you able to have
relationships in that yeah no it was no
I wasn't I was it's just something I did
you know I had to I had to find it how
to hunt it down right I mean anytime I
went to a hotel I would open up the
Yellow Pages and look for massage
parlors and look for you know some weird
thing just to fill the hole and uh and
then you know when I went with my
girlfriend at the time my wife now it
was just
it was terrible I had a bottom and it
was like look she's gonna leave
you know she's gone you hit a bottom I
hit a button no no I heard I had to
bottom I mean we got close to that too a
couple times let's be honest
I heard I had to pop oh my God I was you
really had a problem
I'm like you had a real issue
I got clothes man it was a couple times
so when Dawn was like ultimate give me
an ultimatum like you gotta clean it up
yeah dude I was out I tapped out I went
to therapy I had to get my [ __ ] together
I uh it's funny because every friend I
have that you know told me to let her go
and just you're a piece of [ __ ] stop you
you can't do it just let her go find
somebody she deserves you're a piece of
garbage we our group of people is you
would know you want you don't want to
get any advice from them ever the only
person that gave me a good advice was
was uh Colin Quinn yeah he said try to
change try and in eight months if you
can't a year you can't then at least you
tried if you don't you're gonna regret
it for the rest of your life right and
he was I listened to him yeah and I did
you always listen to him you got to any
I did and he saved my life and he saved
my relationship with my wife now the
mother of my child and I got out of it
right you know I got out of it because
it was a it's a bad one man sex is a sex
is a bad one food is the one worst food
is the worst because you can't like well
sexy you don't want you can't get rid of
either but you can you can get rid of a
lot of it yeah you could not [ __ ]
prostitutes and now your girlfriend's
back we could not contribute to sex
trafficking yeah yeah but food did not
get jerked off to a next to a Polo Loco
yeah at 11 but then but then the next
thing is eating in the Pollo Loco and
that's a problem too and well no that's
a good one Apollo Loco is good